hey guys this is the new Reuben report
new old medium ish we're back how about
that we do the last week and here we are
again I am still Dave Rubin and I've got
two of my favorite people Cara Santa
Maria Trayvon free you guys have agreed
to not look at your phones for the
duration of the show it is what you just
pulled that but where is yours are so
afraid argh I offered to take them I'm
not gonna tell you where mine is so here
we go I ran to get here but we're
between a rock and a hard place
Israeli a mess officials have set a
deadline of March 31st for a framework
agreement to control Iran's nuclear
ambitions
however after intense negotiations
obstacle remains on uranium enrichment
where stockpiles and richer radium
should be stored limits on Iran's
nuclear research and development and the
timing and scope of sanction relief
among other issues according to the
Associated Press all right so basically
it sounds like we're shelving this thing
until June because I know we all really
want to hear more about the Iran deal
and the secret negotiations sound think
it's gonna be a framework agreement not
a final agreement it's all about words
and trickery I read a lot I'm on Twitter
and all that stuff I don't know who to
trust with this thing at all so first
off June does that do you think that
makes any difference really pushing this
thing they've been talking about this
for years do you think adding three
months is gonna help us get there I
guess the real question is what is the
intelligence that we have that says that
they are closer than ever to actually
producing a nuclear weapon because it
sounds like the Obama administration
thinks that the restrictions that are
going to be in place that kicking this
thing down the line is actually going to
extend the amount of time that it would
take for Iran to produce something right
but as you said this we've been talking
about this for years why is it all of a
sudden Iran's like oh we should make
nukes a great idea
so isn't this all about who you trust
like everyone keeps a business does the
u.s. trust Iran does a ranter but it's
like I don't even trust our media to
report it properly so how do we spies
like normal people how are we supposed
to decide who do you trust when it comes
to listening
this stuff I mean you I don't think you
can really trust anybody anymore like
they've been saying Iran's close to
making a bomb for the last 25 years it's
like what are they doing some like
tantric bomb there's so close it's like
eventually like when's it gonna explode
like when's it gonna happen but yeah I
get this point how do you even take it
seriously like to me it seems like
trying to get a development deal in
Hollywood just like you keep getting the
details it's like well they want to
develop this script like now say well
let's do this take three months and like
decide what we were to do here is like
well wait a year and just like they take
your development deal away and you're
like I [ __ ] the easiest correlation
for me yeah things I feel their pain
it's like you just want to get this
script made and they're like but but but
yeah so as part of it that that they've
literally everyone's been talking about
this for so long like that's why this
seems so ridiculous to me because
literally people were talking about this
in Congress in the 80s and we're still
talking about it I don't know that it's
any scarier now maybe it is scarier I
think for me part of the real situation
here is that like who are we to tell
another nation and granted I don't want
Iran to ever write I don't think that's
a good idea so there's a philosophical
part in like a real part yes who who is
America to tell other nations that they
are not allowed to enrich uranium they
are not allowed to stockpile these
weapons when we are the world leader in
nuclear weapons and we're not willing to
even meet anybody halfway I mean I
remember watching countdown to zero that
amazing documentary about disarmament
like five years ago and just crying
because I was just so depressed by the
fact that we are not setting a good
example here and the truth of the matter
is it's easy when we live in America and
we sit on this cookie cushy couch to go
oh we would never make a mistake yeah
[ __ ] crazy right so do you see that
distinction there's like a philosophical
thing where it's like well who were we
to tell anyone but at the same time I
don't think any of us
to have a bomb right no I feel like
we've become like America is the other
the rest of the world's parent and there
are kids off to college and we're like
hey if you want my money this is what
you're gonna do
yeah I'm gonna date that guy you're not
gonna go to that party and I'm gonna
keep paying your tuition so I was like
if you want to make a bomb
fine but you won't get any money for us
and you're by the way that's exactly
what my parents say to me when I went to
college they were like if you want to
keep which is smarter fit if we are the
parents of the rest of the world we're
like the crack addict oh yeah we're the
worst parents like we're the do it do as
I say not as I new parent right like
that's something we have to remember as
much as we're like you Ron should not
have a bomb think about all the Iranian
so we're probably good right like we
have the bomb because we know what to do
with it we're gonna keep them safe but
you can't have a bomb cuz we don't trust
you and by the way we're not only the
only ones that have used them but we use
them more than once and not just that we
are also like excessively using drone
strikes where I mean they're a force in
and America and force like go together
like peanut butter and jelly if we start
talking drone strikes right now this
thing will never end anyway ha ha ha ha
nukes
should Iran happen do we've any right to
tell them not to what should the world
do and who do you trust let us know in
the comments right down below you say
Isis I say [ __ ] [ __ ] does Lama
k-state's children have taken center
stage in their latest propaganda video
the new video posted on social media
Tuesday claims to show Isis fighters
cutting off the heads of 8 men said to
be Shiite Muslims hostages were said to
be beheaded in the central Syrian
province of kumoi
after young boys like each hostage into
a field before handing knives to
fighters the Syrian Observatory for
Human Rights says that the video is
authentic all right so we've done a
bajillion Isis videos at this point
already and every time we do one now I
have to start the conversation by saying
how desensitized to this stuff are you
at this point like when you see those
pictures are you just like ah it's all
that land sadly it's super desensitizing
because you they don't realize like to
me it's like the Kevin Hart effect is
like if you do it too much if you're
around too much I don't care about
anything that you do anymore because I
see it every day it's like trailer
trailer Kevin our Kevin Hart Isis
just go away for a little while take six
months off come back and cut off a head
now go oh my god that's so horrible I
mean this it's I haven't seen me yet but
you know what now I want to see I've
watched all the rest of their videos
yeah but I'm totally with you on that
that we've seen so much of this did you
guys actually watch any of the
beheadings or watch the guy burning the
Jourdain eye I am a crazy person and I
did watch the burning video yeah I like
I've seen worse I'd Ruben Compton and I
feel like it's a like some people like I
can't watch it but I feel like you need
to see what they're doing in order to
really really understand what's
happening and as crazy as it is I think
by not seeing it makes it easier for us
to detach ourselves from gonna go like I
don't really care what's going on over
there I don't know what yeah so yeah
what do you think I don't watch them and
because of that I'm not desensitized to
it
I mean it horrifies me every single it
makes me it makes me angry like it
doesn't decent-size me to it it makes me
feel like more passionate about what we
should do about right so is that is that
the catch-22 though because on one hand
they put these videos out so that we get
in rage because in a way they want us to
bomb them because then that just that's
why we should bomb that that's why the
food is like they want there they have
this idea that they're supposed to the
idea is we're supposed to go this in the
fighting them and we meet them and I
think the beak and it's supposed to be
this big end of the world war right and
that's literally and that's what they
want right so [ __ ] give it to ya we
go there yeah meet them there Obama gets
on camera like our WWE wrestler he's
like I'm gonna meet you in the beak and
I'm gonna bring my drone I'm gonna bring
my bombs and we meet there and we
[ __ ] obliterate them and we go back
home and finish house of cards writes
for The Daily Show and it's not in
charge of foreign problem because here's
the thing we do meet them halfway and we
do bomb them and
their recruitment efforts go through the
[ __ ] roof yeah the worst thing that
we can do is give Isis more reason to
hate the West and to get more kind of
fundamental in intensely anti Western
Muslims to join with this
I think that's based on the idea that
you can actually negotiate with these
people and if they're reasonable people
and they're not right you can't like
approach them like reasonable people
like well if we don't attack you and you
won't know how to recruit regardless
right so your propaganda
excuse regardless you think that if we
can't try to empathetically understand
where they are coming from and why their
efforts are the way that they are that
we can't start to understand the
psychology of what it means to be in
Isis I think that the Atlantic article
that came out how long ago was that now
maybe a month ago that really talked
about how religious Isis actually is and
tried to put you know kind of an
intellectual face on that I think was
incredibly important for Americans to
understand exactly who we're dealing
with instead of just going there [ __ ]
crazy people no matter what we do
they'll just always be crazy there's a
real reason behind what they're doing
it's not legitimate at all but it's real
and it's there and it's based on these
early religious texts right so is that
the place that we should be somewhere
between neocon like do nothing right
because yeah that's the thing that I'm a
liberal so I stand up for liberal
principles meaning I stand up for women
and Ferguson for minorities so they're
doing horrible things to those groups of
people so I want to stand up for it on
the other hand I'm not a war monger so I
don't just want to attack them and I
feel like that's where most I was before
I got to the just [ __ ] because yeah
just [ __ ] get rid of it like I spent
so much time like college take this
approach and do this and this is and
eventually you just see this like what
are you gonna do it's so infuriating
we're just like it's easy to just [ __ ]
just go so then using more rationale of
why they do what they do then what do
you do besides do that I mean I think a
part of it is to make sure that we're
working with the international community
to protect the people who are at risk of
being injured but to protect Syrian city
to go into these places where people are
you know and get people out if they are
under Isis rule and help people seek
refuge get them out of the country get
them to the places where they're going
to be safer granted that's a utopian
view bombing is much but if we can be
there for these refugees I think that
that's incredibly important all right
well what do you guys think bomb um help
the refugees the truth is probably
somewhere in the middle or something
like that let us know in the comments
right down below there's nothing to fear
but Obama himself according to
Republicans Obama poses a bigger threat
to the US then Putin a Reuters online
poll this month asked 2809 Americans to
rate how much of a threat a list of
countries organizations individuals pose
to the United States on a scale of one
to five with one being no threat and
five being an imminent threat very
Glassner a sociologist and author of the
culture of fear told Reuters the reason
Americans may fear Obama is the media's
fault saying the TV here and American
politics very much trade on fears all
right so Trayvon according to my notes
here you are black is that correct as
last I checked you last you checked ok
so as the black person on the panel is
this all about Obama being black
absolutely I mean what come on are you
serious
more more scary than Putin what could be
more scary than Putin the guy was
elected twice like why would he be more
scarier than Vladimir Putin a guy who
someone who was opposed of him died
right in front of the Kremlin and the
event and he took over the investigation
and they found a guy two days later yeah
and they were cleaning up the blood
before the corpse even cooled off but
like the crazy part is when they pull
these people was like who are they
polling because I feel like they're
pulling the same people who are the
reason why the end of a car commercial
when a car rides on top of a train yeah
I still have to put do not drive your
car on top of on the bottom of the other
commercial because it's like I saw this
thing where a third of Louisiana
Republicans think Obama's to blame for
the slow response to Katrina and he
wasn't even present
Jeff George George W Bush was president
at the time so like I don't like it's
even opposed to me seem just like made
to drum up that like let's make a story
so hate Obama I know when we do these
types of stories you always say to me
you want to know more about who the Pugh
of the people are that they talk to yeah
polls are always seem kind of silly and
you know margin of error and all that
the question yeah here's the thing like
and what I love first of all first point
I love that we're all talking about how
people think that he's more of a threat
than Putin but they also think he's more
of a threat than Bush are not in the
headline but the question is not or it
is Obama scarier than the question is
rate these world leaders as to how much
of an imminent threat they are to us
here in America yeah and so these
Republicans see Obama as more of an
imminent threat to America because he is
the president of America than they see
Putin because Putin has literally no
power to do anything to an average
American so in a way you're sort of
actually giving not that you agree with
you know I mean you're giving them
credit for at least being true to their
principles it won't believe that this
guy is taking the country down Morris
that's if there were somebody if there
were an American government like if you
were to ask me who's more of an imminent
threat to America Vladimir Putin or Ted
Cruz right I might say Ted Cruz because
Ted Cruz has power to to affect
legislation that can be very detrimental
to our science policy in the country and
Putin is you know shirtless on a horse
like I don't think that he's really
gonna wrecked my life now I feel
horrible for like literally everybody
that was in Russia right but have to see
those pictures on a date is just
terrible but yeah I don't think he's an
imminent threat to me as an American
citizen this is what I hope the last
year of Obama's presidency he just wears
a hoodie he just every press really goes
just like just yeah I do want to be
afraid now be afraid so are you shocked
that after six years of this guy being
president whether you agree with him or
not and we all know our debate is just
so stupid in this country
everyone hates someone or you love them
and there's nothing in between but are
you shocked that the state of race
relations is sort of where it's at which
seems to be a lot worse I was six years
old you'd not think that that's the case
I don't think in in the long game it got
worse but I think in this concentration
of this last six years I think it
definitely got worse and I think once
you saw him get elected it's no secret
why the threats against the president
are at an all-time high in the history
of this country no presidents ever had
more deference and Obama and all the
racist stuff you've every time we've had
a racist or any type of email scandal
this year from Sony to the Ferguson
Police Department there's a Obama races
email in all of them which is like why
is that right like that's the uniform
right these stories like they all have
to make racist jokes about the president
it's like it's it's everywhere
yeah race do you think do you feel the
same way like I totally agree like I
think in the long term we're in a better
we're in better shape of course they're
better but we have these blips where it
just seems like right now it seems like
it's much worse yeah I mean I think that
that is to be expected I think that we
kind of all knew that as progressives
going in that if and when Obama won his
election and we all were totally rally
behind him in 2008 at least that this
was going to piss a lot of people off
and sometimes I think that the slow
build is not the way that we see
progress I think the way that we see
progress is we put people in really
uncomfortable situations and they have
to just deal with it and get through it
and I think for a lot of people in this
country who are racists to all say it
Obama was an uncomfortable situation and
the truth is he's been in their face now
for six years they have to [ __ ] deal
with it and the the real progress I
think is gonna come when we have another
black president and oh geez is the other
day not going away
will happen again and when it happens
more and more and more people are gonna
be less and less freaked out about it
and then we'll actually see that you
know looking back on the timeline we're
in a much better place than we were yeah
all right is is Putin scarier than Obama
could we possibly have another black
president oh my god people are freaking
out let us know in the comments right
down below
shocker cigarettes are bad for you so
put that in your pipe and smoke it a new
study published in the New England
Journal of Medicine says that
e-cigarette vapor can Harbor hidden
formaldehyde a known carcinogen at
levels up to 15 times greater than
regular cigarettes it has the potential
to distribute deeply into the lungs and
collect air alright so last time that
karo is on the show we talked about
e-cigarettes we're gonna annotate to it
right here and there's a link down below
to the segment and you were talking
about some of the health problems
related to e-cigarette and people were
going bananas on you in the comments
mostly ecig smokers saying that there
are no health problems but Wow
more science just a couple months later
yeah I mean granted I I don't want to I
don't want to say that I didn't maybe
speak a little out of turn because I
think the quote was something like they
are just as bad for you as regular
cigarettes which the truth is the jury's
still out
I was speaking more in the context of
they're just as addictive as regular
cigarettes they're just as bad for you
when it comes to your you know nicotine
habit is regular cigarettes but yes it
seems like every time a new study comes
out about e-cigarettes it just
reinforces the fact that guys this is
not a panacea there's just no way to
smoke in a healthy way
we wish there were which is why you
should be having edibles when it comes
to we've exactly do you want to get rice
krispies treat right it's so funny that
people just want to feel good about this
horrible habit that they have it's like
if I just slap some quinoa on this
Baconator are the reason won't clog is
fast or I won't feel as bad to me
because I could I came while today I
don't think you leave out the other part
but I mean you're smoking at the end of
the day you're smoking tobacco and you
know you got formaldehyde yeah like that
must make you feel great
why do you think people are so defensive
about this because I really did think it
was interesting in the comments on that
video that we did and again you said you
weren't an expert in this particular
thing but people were took it so
personally and I guess it's to your
point like people just want to believe
that something could actually be okay
with you I feel similar to like religion
where you like if someone tells you what
you believe is not you've held on to
this and you've been doing this for
years decades and someone told you
that's not good for you that's not sure
that's gonna kill you and you're like no
if I find one sliver of evidence I said
this is possibly better and good for me
I'm not giving it up that's it so you
think it's like some kind of cognitive
dissonance that they have to have to
smoke because it's killing you and you
know it or you have to because the truth
is like when you when you talk about it
a typical pack of cigarettes you know
we're seeing legislation passed all over
the world that have you know cancer its
mouths pictures of cancerous mouths and
cancerous lungs on the pack of
cigarettes this will kill you in all
capital letters no branding anymore no
cute little cartoon camel and people
look at that go [ __ ] it I'm just doing
it it doesn't matter in granted I can't
speak about this I smoked cigarettes for
years and it was very hard for me to
quit but the last thing I would want to
do after I quit smoking cigarettes is to
pick up an e-cigarette and start the
habit all over again that sounds so
scary to me
granted I think another thing is people
are defensive because some people
actually do use e-cigarettes to quit
smoking and one thing I didn't like
about the article is that it basically
just blew that like it was like yeah
that it's never gonna work it's not good
for you because it assumed that the
people who are using it as a smoking
cessation tool are smoking e-cigarettes
that have the same quantity of tobacco
as a regular nicotine cigarette right
but back when I quit smoking this was
before you've ached are you open enough
to say back when I this was before
vaping it was before these like douchey
looking cigarettes and before you would
drive down the street there's like vape
store I had to order it online from this
website that looked like it was made by
an eight-year-old and and they were they
look like cigarettes and the white part
was a battery in the little brown part
like the filter was the cartridge and
what you would do is you would order a
pack that it was a step-down pack the
cartridge was guarded
full nicotine and it would step down to
no nicotine by the time you were done
with it I don't think people are doing
that with these babies cigarettes I
think they're just yes I think that I
wish you could have done this whole
thing in grandma's trying to can you
just do the end of it and grandmas oh
that's actually not good I'm gonna try
it again I'm gonna don't smoke on my
lawn not good for you not being highly
highly addictive don't start with an
e-cigarette
you don't be like Jenny McCarthy okay so
that's that's how I work so that's how I
want to wrap this thing up so Jenny
McCarthy has been doing commercials for
e-cigarettes at least was up until I
haven't seen in the last really great
scientists right yes yes she also is
against vaccine people what do you make
of her play in this like she'll take
money knowing at worst case scenario she
knows the science is out on the ESA's
right thing she had no problem taking
money from them at the same time the
science basically proves you're so right
she's like we need more testing on these
vaccines they run for Congress because
that's a congressman stands by the way
she [ __ ] that's what I'm saying we're
really what do you make of someone like
that that can be like so outspoken on
one thing related to science and the
other hand just completely dismiss it
come in I think he's going to just how
[ __ ] her whole thing is or it's like
you have doctors and all these like
associations telling you vaccines don't
cause autism vaccines don't cause autism
now every kid in California is getting
the measles because she's on TV we're
listening to the Playboy model tell us
don't back send your kids but she's on
she's like taking money to tell you like
each cigarettes are good for you they're
better for you whenever 15 times more
from out
ginnis like no no it's fine and then she
takes the check and runs it like come on
everybody's got a price I guess do the
thing that kills you do the thing that
kills you don't do the thing that kills
your kids to quote Trayvon don't take
advice from former Playboy models like
the Wicked Witch of the West ant are
is melting according to The Weather
Underground Antarctica has experienced
its warmest day ever on Tuesday March
24th with the temperature reading at
sixty three point five degrees
Fahrenheit prior to this date the
highest known recorded temperature on
the continent was 62 46 degrees
Fahrenheit back in the 1976
I know I know Antarctica has its highest
temperature ever but it has nothing to
do with climate change there's nothing
that humans are doing that is making any
of this stuff happen
[ __ ] happens that's what Donald Trump at
least is gonna tweet when you see
something right or with the people that
you know it starts snowing and they say
well there can't be global warming cuz
it's snowing remember there was that
congressman just a couple weeks ago with
the snow I mean something is happening
to this earth right science girl yes and
the other argument that you often hear
from the conservative party is that
there's more ice in Antarctica there's
more ice you guys so this couldn't be a
global warming issue but what they fail
to distinguish between is land ice and
sea ice and because of global climate
change and because of the the patterns
of the winds from global climate change
we will see from time to time
more sea ice this is what happens when
there's sea ice you take a glass of
water that has ice cubes in it and the
Ice Cube's melt and then let's say that
they freeze again and they melt and they
freeze good and the level of the water
stays the same because its water in
water when the land ice melts it's
[ __ ] catastrophic it falls into the
ocean and the ocean levels rise adjusted
it and it makes Florida disappear so
just to be clear you know you were very
clear but I wanted is really clear this
thing out so when the land ice melts
that water has to go somewhere
all into the ocean plus water raises and
Florida and New Orleans and as water as
water heats up it actually expands we've
got we've got a two-fold problem the
water itself is expanding and the water
is taking in ice that's falling off of
the land into the ocean to extend that
seva sea level rise even more this is
incredibly dangerous we're starting to
see that when the land gets warm like
this it actually melts the ice from
underneath so it slips off like it's
supposed to be pretty well stuck too
the land but we're seeing these warming
pockets underneath these massive ancient
glaciers and the ice is literally just
sliding into the ocean and as you said
you can look at these renderings these
world map renderings and there's
horrifying California's underwater
Florida's underwater and the thing is we
don't feel it here we don't feel it
because we live in America and the air
conditioner blows are nice and cold but
if you go and you visit these low-lying
nations these places like Bangladesh
where people are literally underwater
when they weren't five years ago its
climate change is happening right now
yeah ironically we're in a drought in
California but that's that's a whole
other thing so when you hear someone
explain science like that does it give
you any hope that the people that don't
believe in this stuff and for some
reason don't believe in science isn't
you believe it it's a factor even it or
not that's the thing well that's the
thing like the guy who brought the
snowball yeah on the floor is in charge
of the science committee or in Congress
it was like how do you expect anything
to change what bad guys keeper of the
gate yeah he's like I got a snowball so
it's nothing going on out yeah exactly
like that that's the guy in charge but
like when you think about the people on
the right and why they push back so hard
against climate change
like I saw reluctantly I saw Dennis
Miller's Netflix special and he does
this joke yeah I don't know I'm sadistic
and he says if global warming is real
like someone just showed me why it's
snowing or why it's cold and the
audience just applause and goes crazy
and it's like that's why the earth is
gonna die because the other half of the
people don't get it they just like so
why is this a political thing that's the
part I don't get what being a
conservative or being a liberal has
anything to do with science like I don't
understand how this has become like this
political thing we're to be like I'm if
you say I'm running as a Republican I
have to be against science it's actually
crazy well the funny thing is that
environmentalism as you actually look
into the research doesn't seem to be
progressive specifically a progressive
issue many conservatives are quite
environmentalist in their methods they
just like a different message than we do
liberals seem to like a message of like
Go Green and be good for the planet
hug each other and and conservatives
they're pretty sickening - thanks true
but conservatives are like don't [ __ ]
preach to me don't tell me about my
consumer rights and so I think if you
approach it from different angles you
can actually feed into conservative
environmentalism in a smart way we just
haven't had a good you know we haven't
had a good go of it because we as
progressives have horrible PR and we
don't know what the [ __ ] we're doing
when it comes to marketing a message
conservatives are very good at that so I
think the truth of the matter is it's
not that most Republicans are anti
global warming it's that Republican
leaders are in their pockets there's a
specific political agenda here yes and
they're in the pockets of big oil and
big fossil fuel no incentives so so is
that it though that why don't they then
start putting some of their resources
into green stuff and just make money
with green like that seems so obvious to
me like if you're not denying the sign
right well then there's plenty of but
but it's gonna be there so don't we're
not thinking about the future we're
thinking about the right now there's a
lot of legacy money in fossil fuels and
these pockets go deep and these
relationships go back a very long time
yeah and the old people in charge of
these institutions they don't want
change they want to stick to what
they've been doing until you hit rock
bottom and there's nothing less exactly
right meaning you want to deplete the
oil base it the way it's always been
progressivism requires discomfort it
requires trying things and seeing things
fail and learning from those mistakes
and pushing past it conservatism is not
about that it's about maintaining the
status quo and holding on to the way
that things were for as long as you
possibly can until it becomes
detrimental and the truth of the matter
is the ship is [ __ ] sinking right now
right and we all love to say that we're
ruining the planet we're ruining the
planet but we sometimes what we
sometimes forget is that you know
Jurassic Park life will find a way the
planet although it will be badly damaged
we'll figure out how to go on without us
what we're doing right now is we're
making the planet unlivable for us
but also for a lot of other [ __ ]
species along the way which is a huge
bummer yeah
but the truth be told we won't be able
to survive on earth if we continue on
the track that we're continuing earth
we'll figure it out without us I was
just watching that George Carlin special
and that basically is what he says that
you know uh you know the earth was here
for billions of years before you know
and it's gonna be here way after we've
had to leave you know ten of us are
gonna have to leave - I just watch deep
impact you know I want to I want to be
one of those eight hundred thousand
people yeah anyway what do you guys
think why is science a political issue I
cannot believe that it is in 2015
let us know your thoughts in the
comments right down below the dog ate my
homework thank God it was gonna kill me
in a new study published in the Journal
of educational psychology researchers
found that there really is such thing as
too much horror when researchers from
Spain measured the academic performance
of 7725 private and public school
students in the math and science
they found that students who spend about
ninety to a hundred minutes on homework
tend to see their grades go on a decline
while those who study between 70 to 90
minutes a day found a slight increase on
their grades all right I can honestly
say that in high school I barely ever
did homework I did my homework in the
classes before the class that I was
supposed to bring in the homework to do
in the first place Trevon I was at your
birthday party this weekend I met some
of your high school friends they said
you were a very good student and they
did all your homework on time do you
think it was a detriment or did it help
you no I think it was I mean listening
to that those numbers I think it helped
cuz I was in that 70 to 90 range I
didn't have that's 100 minutes of
homework that sounds crazy that's a lot
of homework yeah I remember having like
two pages of something to do the
occasional end of the semester like ten
page report but like a hundred minutes
that's that sounds like a lot of
homework especially when curriculums
have improved so it wasn't like you had
those teachers from like the 90s or
their like 80s who like didn't really
give a [ __ ]
they were doing a class here take this
to go home and do this right yeah but
like now they're actually teaching kids
more and teaching them better like
curriculums and so I get why adding a
hundred minutes of homework on top of
that might make kids a little like huh
like this is exhausting yeah I mean so I
didn't do much I would do homework in
school as I said but or I'd borrow it
for somebody or side
figure it out away but I was a pretty
good student overall but the idea of
this hundred minute thing or the idea
that these teachers feel or the
curriculum forces them to be like oh I
give this student 45 minutes of work
after we leave it's not like an inherent
flaw in the teaching process like they
have these kids no you know these are
they they have these kids all day right
from like 8 to 3 or whatever it is
nobody you have that guy so you have
that kid for an hour an hour whatever it
is but you get homework from each
teacher no that's that's my point that
that there's no way of balancing it
quite correctly and then you're just
slamming these kids and growing up also
has things to do that you find out about
things that aren't in books right I
completely agree that's completely true
I think part of the reason that this
study is a little bit misleading is that
we're pulling out a very small outcome
of the study and we're like obsessing
over this homework thing right but the
truth of the matter is this study was
trying to look at the effects of
homework overall and they accounted for
all these differences right like
socioeconomic status and gender and age
and all these different things and the
most salient thing that they found that
was more effective than all the other
factors combined was prior knowledge the
kids that were already more
knowledgeable going in always had higher
scores on standardized tests than the
kids that weren't combine that with how
much homework are they doing how how you
know personally driven is the homework
how autonomous is it all these little
like parsing is at 60 minutes is at 70
minutes is it a hundred minutes those
are very small almost statistically
insignificant effects the most
significant effects here were that the
kids were knowledgeable and that the
kids were self driven in doing their
homework so I think the thing that's
important to remember is that if you're
already a shitty student and then you
sit there for an hour every day or two
hours every day staring at the page it's
not gonna help it might actually make
you more tired the next day when you go
in to take the exam right but if you're
a student who's already really into it
and you know how to do your homework
it's actually probably going to help if
you go home and do independent reading
an independent study yeah so where is
the school that I was always looking for
the school that you'd go to during the
in the second you get out of there they
don't want to know anything about you
till the next day and if anything they
tell you to get out there and run around
and be outside right please we're like
what why don't we have more of that is
that school really going to help prepare
you for your how many times Dave do you
leave work and literally not think about
work until you show up the next morning
well now the phone I think about it all
we also we also love what we do though I
think right the fact that like even when
I got here yeah I couldn't stop watching
the news and I'm not even trying it's
just like a habit or it's like this is
the thing that I'm interested in so I
ended up turning it on I go what the
[ __ ] am i doing turn it off like go have
fun this is my vacation but I think for
people like us like I assumed we were
all driven students who liked what we
were who cared about education and so
homework and that stuff came natural and
easy to us and I had a lot of friends
who were shitty students and a part of
continuing to be a shitty student is
having shitty teachers and having shitty
programs and that schools not having
money so those kids can like you were
saying continue to be shitty students
and the teachers started to focus on the
kids that they see promising and they
kind of like fall away from those kids
of it that kids not going anywhere right
so it's you see my president so I'm
gonna focus on him and I got a classroom
that's oversized I got 40 kids seven of
them are great and the other like 33 are
so if I can with my thirty thousand
dollar salary make something out of
these seven kids I'm gonna focus on
these seven kids yeah I mean that's a
really great point because then it's so
systemic that it's not even the teachers
fault in them yeah it should be how they
don't have the manpower or at a time or
the resource you have to choose between
who do I try to like loosely educate
this entire class and don't give and
give them a watered-down education or
try to really get something out of these
kids that I see potentially and also try
to help these other kids even though
chances are like I went to school in
Compton so I've seen it all like I've
seen teachers who didn't give a [ __ ]
when just put on the movie and I seen
teachers who really care like part of
the reason I got into writing and really
focused on it was because I had a
teacher pull me aside and say you're
really good at this you should focus on
this more and has that not happened I
probably wouldn't be doing what I'm
doing because I was just playing sports
and going to class
yeah a little sliver of hope think about
how much culture plays into this like
you were talking about growing up in
Compton it's not cool to be good at so
when you live in these areas and if we
felt that yes I have social pressure to
to not be into knowing things I have
made fun for that like we talked about
it which is so sad we talked about the
fact that we love our jobs and that
makes us want to work when we get home
kids are supposed to love knowing stuff
learning stuff like being aware of the
world around them but when we take all
of the joy out of Education and when we
reinforce in a social way that it's
uncool to be smart and that it's uncool
to be challenged and to know stuff what
do you think is gonna happen I think
that that's the core detriment here is
that we are not a society that really
promotes being special and being smart
and being intellectual look at Congress
right now this is not a core value that
we promote in our society all right so I
think there you go if you want to be
like Congress don't do your home if you
want to be like these three great people
right here do your homework anyway let
us know what you think in the comments
right down below the first selfie stick
ban is here god bless america
right on Coachella's list of rules in
big capital letters braids no selfie
sticks
Coachella isn't the only music event of
a mistake Lollapalooza has taken a
stance against the stick saying in its
rules and regulations that GoPro
attachments like sticks selfie sticks
and mono
are not allowed all right so we've done
a bunch on social media of course where
we've talked about selfie sticks they
drive me [ __ ] crazy I just can't
explain it
we're all attached to our phones I know
it's ironic that me for as much as I use
my phone and all that that's someone
else the way they do it right we're
driving me this crazy yeah you want to
add your selfie stick glad you're taking
this out but we live in such a culture
of that and now we're seeing it where
people are literally just walking we're
intrude you were born with two selfie
sticks why do you need two let's go but
I saw people in Times Square with a
selfie stick and it was driving me nuts
because one you're not paying to see
your surroundings you're doing this and
like whacking people in the head and
it's like it's bad enough like I see
people doing it it's like I can't tell
if they're blind or take a selfie right
or there's a phone ataxia that takes
over anyway there's another idiot like
walking around with their felt like why
do you need to take Celt like the
museum's just bandim yeah but you can't
even take him I think it's the Met or
the moment one of the museum's it's like
you're gonna knock over some like ten
thousand euros face cuz you guys want to
take a selfie with the Mona Lisa like
yeah I have I totally agree like so we
live in this culture where clearly like
we're making everything about ourselves
all the time I'm really trying not to
take selfies especially you always see
people taking selfies when they're
surrounded by other people there used to
be you could just ask someone to take a
picture of you right have a perfectly
fine picture but now like you they want
this idea this thing is everything that
social media is leading to just like
it's just II go you go II go right like
is that just where this is all going
part of but I don't think that's a new
thing I think it's just that we have the
technology now to allow it yeah I mean
if you look at like core American
principles of kind of like manifest
destiny like God gave me the United
States and just like I earned this
because like we have this very
individual to society you compare us to
Asian societies to other societies from
the east and like across the board
they're hilarious studies where kids
in New York I don't even know if it's
New York but like American kids take
these exams where they are asked are you
smarter than X percentage of the other
people and the number is ridiculously
high it's like I am smarter than 70% of
my peers when you ask the same kids in
China and they're like 10% but the kids
in China are like significantly smarter
in exams they do so much better like you
can't be smarter than 90% of your peers
when you're making an F in your classes
ya think you are right that's the
culture we live so then what do you make
of this that this clearly isn't just an
American thing though because people are
doing this all over the world I think
it's I think it's a big part of the fact
that we now get to walk around with a 10
megapixel camera everywhere we go
yeah and we can take a photo at any time
we well like you used to have to take a
picture wine the thing click take it to
the Rite Aid in the local store wait a
few days from the kid develop and they
come back now you got instant photos
everywhere you go and the another thing
I really like gets under my skin is the
fact that people call them selfies when
there's like three people in it like
that it's in the dictionary now that's
not a selfie if there's you and your
four friends that's not a sellout you
truly are a writer because only a writer
would get this I bet it's a groupie at
best there's like selfie of so-and-so
and you're like that's just a photo
place and it's not even the picture them
doing it it's just them together taking
your photos and they're surrounded by
people that could have taken the picture
of them like when Obama was at Mandela's
memorial and he took the picture with
Africa which country all the reports are
like Obama in unappropriate selfie with
three other people you're like come on
you're the news yeah like at least call
it what it is a photo wow you still
expect the news to say things anyway it
is I'm I'm a hopeless believer that one
day we'll get it right but we won't yeah
admit something all right
I think tells you that a I'm old
and B I'm totally anti-social I've never
seen a selfie stick in everything around
yeah like a really touristy place I
guess so
I guess so Times Square now they have
people on the corners with tables full
of selfie sticks just like selling
selfies do you realize what a big issue
this actually was because like I would
never in a [ __ ] million years like
duct tape my phone to like a broom I
guess that people do that on a regular
basis yes they leave 8 - it's like it's
douchebaggery cannot be stopped
especially when you can purchase
douchebag accessories it's it's a
marketing scheme really kind of
douchebaggery be stuck let us know in
the comments right now by warning side
effects include excessive humanity a new
drug may help the world become a more
compassionate place researchers at the
universities of California Berkeley and
San Francisco have found that prolonging
the effects of dopamine on the human
brain gives people a greater sense of
empathy to test the behavioral role of
dopamine the researchers conducted a
number of neurological tests and even
games the researchers concluded together
these data shed light on the casual
relationships between neural chemical
systems human pro-social behavior all
right not that shocking this must be why
all the kids are doing the molle right
right doesn't the molle do something to
the dopamine I thought it was next to
see that like made molly's a mixture
though right but it's not pure X's no
Mali's the kurwa I think yeah it was
something else
Wow I mean yeah drugs there are drugs
that can release chemicals in your brain
that can make you happier and more
empathetic and all that so are we gonna
just bottle all of this one day is
everything just gonna is this brave new
world everything will just be bottled
and our emotions were all coming to
pillow form no I don't even understand
why this is a big deal say yes we have
MDMA it actually works on a serotonin
system but we know that dopamine and
serotonin have a complicated interplay
even norepinephrine when it comes to
things like not even alive
nephron which is the epinephrine of the
brain or adrenaline and all of these
things have a complicated interplay when
it comes to depression anxiety happiness
sadness all of that good stuff
dopamine specifically has a lot of
secondary effects so dopamine is also
heavily at play in Parkinson's this is a
drug actually that has been used for
Parkinson's research and part of
Parkinson's treatment so there there can
be totally crazy side effects like
muscular side if that's one years when
you start playing around with these
kinds of drugs but and dopamine also
plays a heavy role in addiction so there
are some dopaminergic drugs that can
actually help you quit smoking for
example wellbutrin has that effect and
what's the other one chantix has that
effects but we've known for a long time
I mean that's what an antidepressant is
I take antidepressants every single day
I take citalopram 20 milligrams every
day it's a it's a selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor maybe having any of
the side effects right now because I
probably I get no side effects except
that I'm really tired but see that
serotonin it's not hope for me and what
it does is it allows me to have enough
serotonin to have a functional normal
healthy amount that keeps me from
getting really really depressed this
idea that dopamine aids in empathy is
interesting it's important it is not a
brave new world there are very few
people on this planet that are fully
lacking empathy they're called so this
is why I bring this why I break out
around I show up she cleans up cleans up
this is for me yeah had a treatment for
sociopathy that might actually be a very
good thing I wouldn't be afraid of that
yeah we could find sociopathy early and
we could treat sociopathy so that
individuals didn't progress to become
murderers or CEOs right I think that may
be right but then it probably brings up
a whole thing like you could look at
kids who may be more prone to be
sociopaths and then you start drugging
them when they're 4 and then what about
their choices in life it's very close to
what we do now right so are we just a
completely over drugged Society in
general we are right I mean even down to
the foods we eat like the stuff that
they put in our foods now has chemical
effects on our brains at it in
twenty or thirty years ago yeah so just
across the board we're taking in if
you're not the kind of person that it's
very strict about what you put in your
body when you eat we're taking in all
kind of stuff we don't even know we're
taking in on top of whatever
prescription drugs were taking on top of
that on top of the second
yeah fifty thousand industrial chemicals
can be found in your blood right now
that didn't exist before like a half a
century it guys so this is just about
money right like everything else like
why is America you guys seen this thing
where they looked at what's in a
McDonald's french fry in America versus
versus I think it's the UK and it's
something like in the UK there's
something like four ingredients but in
America there's like 28 legislate
against putting this crap in the food
anyway we're like where's the money
coming from put it in leave it in if
whoever's paying me to lobby on behalf
of this chemical that they need to put
in these fry whatever like go for it
principal that we know of as regulation
yeah and it's quite important to
regulate things to protect people's
health but the truth is what I worry
about is throwing the baby out with the
bathwater I do worry about people going
oh new drug scary there must be a
nefarious purpose for it all of
Pharmacology is dangerous and evil let's
not even go to the doctor anymore let's
just take herbs into a rain dance thank
you this is a very common progressive
view and it really worries me
vaccines are important medications can
be incredibly important in McCarthy with
it and exactly and life-saving and I
think that psychiatric medications are
incredibly important if you watched
going clear Scientology at all and you
saw the the just batshit craziness of
Elrond Hubbard and his intense fear of
psychiatry and you understand what that
religion is founded in I think that you
appreciate what psychiatry can do for
people a little right not to get too
sidetracked on that but since you've
read the book I'll say it like pardon
that I thought was the most interesting
was there he clearly had massive
psychological issues oh [ __ ] that
kidnapping his own daughter and saying
to the wife that he had killed her and
all this other stuff and meanwhile all
these people are following him so I
guess there's some there's some lesson
in like religion totally I know there
yeah but Scientology is totally founded
on a fear of psychiatry
in taxes yeah that's a whole wing of the
Republican Party so all right last
thought on this if you guys have one if
there was a pill that you could create
that would do one thing for you what
would it be I would say make writing
jokes easier making the connections
faster and quit like that would be my I
because I love it that's my thing I love
I would say I've had some success appeal
that would make me just like this all
the time and you'd be okay with the
diary and the vomiting and diarrhea i
won bill what do you need I mean I take
a pill that has completely changed my
life so I got to get props to that but
to be honest if there were an empathy PO
that if every single person on the globe
could take it would prevent the the
fundamental problems that we all face
which is really come from a lack of
empathy a lack of understanding what
other people are going through
god damn market the [ __ ] out of that
pill get it it get it in every mouth in
the globe that's a quote right there
someone make a gift for us if I could
take one pill it would definitely be
that I could jump high enough to dunk
can you dunk again you can't I would
make every person on the globe anyway
that is our show I'm gonna let you guys
pimp yourselves out talk to the good
people right Cara Santa Maria at Cara
Santa Maria check out my podcast talk
nerdy Trayvon free I'm at Trayvon on
Twitter know why tra vo Ian and add
Trayvon feelings wow these are true
professionals alright thanks to Trayvon
and Cara and we'll do it again next week
thank you